hallo YouTube just lovers mouflons
this is grunge in here welcome to the
sixth episode of dirty chest tricks
against Sicilian in this lecture I'm
going to show you some of the modern
tricks of 2016 against different
Sicilian setup such as classical
Sicilian Scheveningen Sicilian and
tamaño or Paulsen variation the good
point about districts are they are
frequently occurring about 2,000 fede
rated games so that means the occurrence
of the streaks in your game are very
real after E 4 C 5 the Scheveningen
Sicilian arises after the MU order might
have 3 d6 d4 pawn captures Knight
captures Knight to f6 Knight to c3 and
the move e 6 at this point I'm going to
recommend you should play Sicilian
fianchetto variation which start with
the MU g3 in the recent times Sicilian
fianchetto variation comes into the
limelight the simple reason is it
contains a lot of opening tricks and if
black is not aware of it then black can
get in serious trouble just Orland only
now black and reply in a different
manner but they will all comes to a
critical position which we are going to
observe soon so for example here black
continue with the a6 white plays Bishop
to g2 and after Queen to c7 castle and
Knight to c6 we reach to a very
important Junction as this position can
arise from different order so this is a
standard position you can achieve from
all the Sicilians which I have described
earlier
just to illustrate my point this
position can also be reached by a
different more for example here back
continue with the move tamaño Sicilian
that is e six d4 pawn captures Knight
captures Knight to c6 Knight to c3 Queen
to c7 g3 a6 Bishop to G to d6 castle and
Knight to f6 we dish to pretty much same
position now at this position White has
this wonderful move rook to even which
create a such a nasty trick that no
matter of black replies for example the
most frequent applies over here our
Bishop to e7 or Bishop to d7 but they
all leads disaster to the black
unbelievable right but it's true let's
see them so the first more I want to
consider is Bishop to e7 well after this
White will continue with the Moon Knight
captures kindly note if Queen captures
then ePHI leads to disaster for black so
the force replies pawn captures and now
come this amazing move e5
so attacking two spots so more or less
forcing black to capture the pawn but
then comes this shocking reply rook
captures ePHI first important point if
Queen captures then after Bishop
captures c6 check Bishop to d7 and
Bishop captures rook white emerge with a
simple pawn advantage so that's not good
and if black continues over here with
the move castle on the King side then
you continue with the move Bishop to f4
so there is a discover attack to the
Queen the most logical reply over here
is Queen - b7 attacking b2 but after the
move b3
it's okay material is balanced but you
can see the easiest plan of the campaign
by the white what white wants to do is
to play the move Knight to e4 c4 and
then start attacking this week
and although it looks like a balanced
position why it has a sitting target
where on the counter part black doesn't
have any target in the white camp now
instead of Bishop to e7 if you open and
place the move Bishop to d7 then the
news are even worst and this is a
typical shoveling and moon but here it's
outright mistake because of the same
trick yeah we are going to play the move
Knight captures and now here black has
two choices
but if pawn captures then more or less
same story because we are going to
continue with the movie Phi and after
pawn captures and the move Knight to e5
once again black's pawn structures are
completely destroyed now to illustrate
my point how dangerous this position is
for the black I like to show you one of
my game where my opponent continued here
with the move Bishop to e7
I played the move b3 and after he castle
on the King side I continue with the
move Bishop to b2 so attacking if I my
opponent defended with the move Bishop
to d6 but after Queen to e - not only
that pawn vanished from the game but
later on I managed to create lot of
pressure on those weak bounds is 6 and
c6 and in fact easily converted the full
point so be c6 is not good that means
black has to capture with the bishop
even after capturing with the bishop
black is not out of the wood because now
White has this dazzling move Knight to
d5 haha well what to do now the first
point to note is this Knight is
attacking two spots and let's say black
try to run away with the Queen that is
Queen to d8 then after Bishop to g5
black has some severe issues for example
the normal and the best move over here
is Bishop to e7 but here comes Knight
captures kindly note if pawn captures
then it's a matter of question that
where the black king will go so the most
obvious respond
Bishop captures but then white will
continue with the move Bishop captures
Queen captures and Queen captures d6 so
white is a clear point of and it's not
about capturing upon because why it has
a very sneaky idea
so if black wants to remain on equal
material then black has to capture the
b2 pawn
afterwards white we'll continue with the
move rook to be well I reached this
position in one game where my opponent
continued here with the move Queen
captures a two I reply with the move
rook to d1 and now you can see the dark
side of Queen captures b2 this queen is
stopping black to castle on the King
side and that means why it has all the
chances to finish the game very very
quickly
my opponent continued here with the move
Queen to e5 I responded with the movie
Phi so white is trying to destroy the
last defender and unfortunately black
cannot do much about it
my opponent captured the piece I give
him check and after King to f8 and King
captures g2 it's a hopeless position for
black not only his King is misplaced but
White has a threat of rook captures b7
my opponent responded with the move B
Phi but I think this is a big time
blunder I wonder if you can spot White's
next apply okay I hope you find this
crushing sequence that is Queen to d6
check King to g8 and now the move of the
game rook to e1 and Black has lost the
Queen
the big time problem is if the Queen
moves somewhere let's say Queen to c3
then after Queen to d8 rook captures and
rook captures it's a checkmate
so that means black has to do something
about this night now if black simply
captured with the bishop then the
simplest is you capture with the pawn
and after the move e5 where it has a
simple bishop pair and all white has to
do is to gradually open the game to show
the bishop power so that leads to the
only reply that is what happens if black
captures this piece well after II kept
is defy why it has a simple reply that
is capturing the pawn so we have a
discover attack to the king black plays
Bishop to e7 but now you regain with the
interest so you capture this Bishop and
after the obvious capture we have a
sitting target on this d6 square so
first we are going to stop black to
castle on the Kings side with the move
Queen to e2 of course black has to play
the Mook to a7 in order to castle but
this gives us enough time to arrange the
attack on d6 so here white will continue
with the move Bishop 3
and after the move c5 now you fix the
spawns with the move c4 and after black
castles rook to d1 rook to e8 and Bishop
to f4 I think white has a severe winning
advantage due to the fact that why it
has two wonderful bishops and a sitting
target on d6 to illustrate this I like
to show you a game where black continued
here with the move Bishop to f8
completely overlooking White's next
reply that is Queen captures well what's
the idea the idea is very simple after
Knight captures and rook captures white
is threatening to play the move Bishop
to d6 and nabbing one more piece with a
decisive winning advantage in the game
black continues with the move Queen to
d7 attacking the rook no matter white
continues with the move rook to b8 and
after the move defy rook captures Queen
to e6 and Bishop to d6 only thing left
is black has to play the resign button
that's all guys for this lecture I hope
you enjoy and like my brief analysis and
now you have a new weapon in your armory
thank you for watching this video feel
free to like subscribe and comment on my
video and stay tuned for next upcoming
dirty chess tricks again Sicilian till
then
bye and take care
and he bluntest the rook and and he
resigns well so um yeah that is this is
well well I would a gross miss I hear
Nick coccyx degras mr. procrastinate
evening for me EMU mister